wait will soon be over the white house
just announced president biden will
hold his first formal news conference
next thursday
that will come after 64 days in office
and there is plenty to talk about
the president on the road today selling
his massive stimulus plan as democrats
prepare to spend trillions more
on progressive policies and vice
president harris pushing back against a
reporter who asked
why the white house needs to sell
something that congress has already
passed
the white house has said repeatedly that
that this is a very popular
law if that's the case why is it
important to get out and sell it
it's not selling it it's literally
letting people know their rights right
it's it's kind of like
you um you buy a product you've already
been sold on the product but you need
some directions on the box
think of it more as a public education
campaign as for those progressive
policies president biden is reportedly
preparing for the largest tax hikes
in 30 years and democrats are talking
about spending four trillion dollars on
a green
infrastructure plan so much to get to
katie i have to ask why in the world
would you announce a press conference
nine days from now um my theory is you
announce them that morning because the
press is going to come anyway who knows
what's going to happen in nine days
that is a very good point and dana i
have to give you credit because you were
the one who predicted that the biden
administration would wait until they
passed the rescue plan to hold a press
conference so then they could have
something
to successfully tout and they're doing
this i think nine days from now because
they're going on this long tour right
where they're going to be on the road
trying to sell what's in the rescue
package but there are a lot of questions
for
joe biden the first being you're being
touted as fdr
you're being touted as the most
progressive president uh in
in modern history how is it that you
campaign on being a moderate and what do
you think that people who voted for you
as a moderate
uh should be thinking about your
policies especially if they're looking
at
a tax psych but yes there's a lot that
could happen between now and then
especially with joe biden on the road
and there's a lot of logistics in terms
of how many questions are going to be
asked which reporters will get access to
this especially in the age of kovid
right with this new white house so
lots and lots could happen between now
and next week jesse will you complain
that this press conference is apparently
slated for the afternoon and not prime
time
i feel like someone sent me a save the
date for a wedding that's like a year
and a half from now
nine days is forever in politics so what
i'll see you in nine days joe we'll give
you your best shot
you know the the coven relief package is
the most expensive package
in american history and the white house
touted it as the most progressive
is joe biden going to be able to sell
that no he couldn't even sell himself in
the campaign
he hid in the basement and let the media
do the sales job
and this little sales job's already off
to a rocky start dr
jill biden went to an elementary school
in new jersey to tout the success of
reopenings
and only two kids were in the classroom
the rest of the 17
students were virtually learning after
we showered them with what a half a
trillion dollars so i don't know about
that
then kamala harris goes out to vegas
and visits a vegan taco stand
nothing connects more with the american
people than a
vegan taco stand i don't get that at all
so joe's going to go out and he's going
to claim credit for the vaccines and the
recovery which he has nothing to do with
and then he's going to say oh yeah and
i'm going to raise your taxes
well that's going to get him for me
blame for harming the recovery because
you don't slap
taxes on the american people in the
middle of a recovery
every economist says that he's going to
slap him on
income on corporations and on capital
gains
they're just going to move their money
offshore i mean that's what gut fells
does with his
caymans he puts it offshore and then if
you're going to tell people in a year
from now
you're going to raise capital gains
they're just going to sell off this year
and take their profit so uncle sam can't
take them that'll just tank the stock
market and you add
gas prices to the top of that surging
close to 350 a gallon by this summer
the american people are going to say
yeah what so what coveted relief so what
i don't feel it
i gotta tell you if i were the biden
white house i would watch that segment
for
prep for next thursday because you
mentioned it hit a lot of the issues
but you didn't hit one um and that is
the border uh
joe biden today juan said he's not
planning to go down he
has some uh administration officials
going down there his
uh department of homeland security
secretary today said
hey guys uh don't come don't come yet
you know
it wasn't a don't come it was don't come
yet let us try to get this settled i do
think that the border issue
is definitely going to be one that they
have to deal with next thursday
yeah for sure i think people have lots
of questions about it and he probably
has a lot to say about it
so i think that's appropriate and by the
way dana i thought you predicted this as
katie was saying
that once he got past uh the passage of
the stimulus uh you know he
he would want to talk about it that's
when he would have the pressure i would
tell you that
if i were them i would have done the
press conference the very next morning
i'll let you finish your thought
yeah no well no i appreciate that no i i
think that they can wait i think in fact
as he goes out
to the countryside and talks the
american people directly
i think this could be kind of like an
ultimate you know
note in that in that presentation and he
has a lot to say obviously they're going
out there they've got slogans
help is here a shot in the arm you know
money in your
pocket all of those are going to i think
be driven home you know it's like ronald
reagan used to say
i the first time i say it they don't
hear it it's the tenth time i say it
that people start to register
and i think that's what you're going to
get from biden i mean biden to me
you know in response to what katie was
saying say he's got a popular product to
sell so this is like
coca-cola or the ford f-150 yeah they're
popular
but you still see ads on tv for it and
so biden's going to say
70 of the american people like this
product
how is that a radical product how is
that not in keeping
with a moderate american mainstream the
other thing greg
we didn't mention yet i mean there's
lots of questions that they could be
asked like
the iran nuclear deal the fact that the
customs and border patrol just confirmed
today that at least four people have
crossed the border
illegally that they have caught that
were on the terrorist watch list and we
haven't talked about
governor cuomo i mean it's wide open
yeah first of all uh
you talk about selling a product i think
the closest analogy although analogies
aren't perfect
are uh shoes made by sweatshops it's
like everybody likes those shoes but
they don't really know where they come
from
uh the nine days dana uh more than
enough time to create the deep fake
so that's what they're doing right now
um but i do want to talk about um
this uh this this budget in the raising
of taxes because i think that's the
that's the big story what is amazing is
we know now
that small government is dead and it was
dead before covet
and it's never coming back but what
makes the democrats so damn
absurd is that they can make recent
examples of big government spending
look positively tiny by
in mere months right so i'm trying to
you know not only is small government
dead
big government is dead we are now in xxl
government we are looking forward to
what comes after
trillion which is quadrillion president
uh
harris in two years will introduce a
budget with
with one and 15 zeros and then we're
gonna have to ask ourselves and this is
the best question of all
what are the long terms effect of this
tax and spend
uh creation it's inevitably going to
the money's going to run out and the
economy is going to crash and who does
that hurt
it hurts the children the children that
the left always claims to care about
you know when they barf up these green
new deals or uh
or wave children across the border and
here you essentially guarantee a cliff
at the end of this tunnel
but the good news is this is the good
news the left claims that the planet
only has what eight or nine years left
which is exactly when the money runs out
so we won't have any money
so it's a perfect time for the entire
planet
we're going to mars and to katie's point
the people that were selling us on a
centrist joe
don't have to worry about left-wing joe
the people they lied to
have to worry about it the people that
are going to be taxed and the people
that are going to lose their jobs
because the rich aren't going to be
spending that much more money anymore
i just had a picture of the government
shopping at the big and tall shop
yes xxxl they should call it tyrus
government
tyrus size all right coming up much more
on